so let's think about how we could find
the slope of the tangent line to this
curve right over here so what I've drawn
in red at the point x equals a and we've
already seen this with the definition of
the derivative we could try to find a
general function that gives us the slope
of the tangent line at any point so
let's say we have some arbitrary point
let me define some arbitrary point X
right over here then this would be the
point X comma f of X and then we could
take some x + H so let's say that this
right over here is the point X plus h
and so this point would be X plus h f of
X plus h we can find the slope of the
secant line that goes between these two
points so that would be your change in
your vertical which would be f of X plus
h f of X plus h minus f of X minus f of
X over the change in the horizontal
which would be X plus h minus X X plus h
minus X minus X and these two x's cancel
so this would be the slope of this
secant line and then if we want to find
the slope of the tangent line at X the
slope of the tangent line at X we would
just take the limit the limit of this
expression as H approaches 0 as H
approaches 0 this point moves towards X
and that slope of the secant line
between these two is going to
approximate the slope of the tangent
line at X and so this right over here
this we would say is equal to this is
equal to F prime of X this is still this
is a function of X you give me an X you
give me an arbitrary X that where the
derivative is defined I'm going to plug
it into this whatever this ends up being
it might be some nice clean algebraic
expression that I'm going to give you a
number so for example if you wanted to
find you you could calculate this
somehow or you could even leave it in
this form and then if you wanted F prime
of a if you wanted F prime of a you
would just substitute a into your
function definition and you would say
well that's going to be the limit
as H approaches zero of every place you
see an X replace it with an A f of I'll
stay in this color for now blank plus h
minus minus F minus F of blank minus F
of blank all of that over all of that
over H and I left those blanks so I
could write the a I could write the a in
red notice every place where I had an X
before it's now an A so this is the
derivative evaluated at a so this is one
way to find the slope of the tangent
line when x equals a another way and
this is often used as the alternate form
of the derivative would be to do it
directly so this is the point a comma F
of a let's just take another arbitrary
point some here someplace so let's say
this is the value X this point right
over here on the function would be X
comma f of X and so what's the slope of
the secant line between these two points
what would be change in the vertical
which would be f of X minus f of a minus
F of a over a change in the horizontal
over X minus a so let me do that purple
color over X minus a now how can we get
a better and better approximation for
the slope of the tangent line here well
we could take the limit as X approaches
a as X gets closer and closer and closer
to a the secant line slope is going to
better and better and better approximate
the slope of the tangent line this
tangent line that I have in red here so
we would want to take the limit the
limit as as X approaches a here either
way we're doing a very similar we're
doing the exact same thing we're finding
that we're taking this we're have an
expression for the slope of a secant
line and then we're bringing those those
X values of those points closer and
closer together closer and closer
together so the slopes of those secant
lines better and better and better
approximate that slope of the tangent
line and at
limit it does become the slope of the
tangent line that is the derivative of
that's the definition of the derivative
so this is the clot that kind of the
more standard definition of a derivative
it would give you your derivative as a
function of X and then you can then
input your X that you want your the the
particular value of x or you could use
the alternate form of the derivative if
you know that hey look I'm just looking
to find the derivative exactly at a I
don't need a general function of F then
you could do this but they're doing the
same thing